hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
symbolisch werden heute ein herzhaftes
türkisches gericht zaubern und zwar gibt
es nudeln schmecken aus dem backofen und
ich habe ja schon mal nudeln schmecken
gemacht aber diese hilfen ganz anders
vor allen dingen ist die technik wie man
die später auch wirklich ganz anders und
ich sehe wirklich wunderschön aus dafür
werde ich jetzt erstmal einen nudelteig
zu bereiten
da ist der nudelteig ein bisschen anders
und nicht so typisch sag ich mal den ist
einfach weniger eier verwendet auf die
jeweilige mail menge für den nudelteig
brauche ich 800 gramm mehl 2 eier und
400 bis 450 milliliter wasser zuerst
einmal werden wir jetzt das mädel eine
rührschüssel geben
ihr könnt den teig natürlich auch gerne
per hand verkneten ja aber dritten sehr
fester teil jetzt noch die eier mit dazu
jetzt kommt noch das wasser mit dazu da
kommt jetzt aber nicht alles rein denn
je nachdem wie groß die eier waren
braucht jetzt etwas mehr oder etwas
weniger jetzt kneten wir einen schönen
festen aber trotzdem geschmeidigen
nudelteig
der teig ist jetzt fertig und muss jetzt
noch ein bisschen hohen die zwischenzeit
kann ich aber nutzen um die füllung
vorzubereiten
ok und dann ein vater rhein okay
ich werde jetzt die nudeln schmecken mit
einer hackfleisch füllung gefühlt aber
ihr können sie zum beispiel auch
vegetarisch mit einer kartoffel zu
laufen
das ist nämlich auch sehr lecker für die
hackfleisch will brauche ich 800 gramm
hackfleisch 14 rinder hackfleisch
zwiebeln eine knoblauchzehe und dann
noch ein paar gewürze ein teelöffel
curry einen teelöffel oregano einen
halben teelöffel chili und etwas pfeffer
ich werde zuerst einmal die zwiebeln und
die knoblauchzehe ganz fein würfeln
hier zeigten die zutaten alle
miteinander vermischt mit zwiebel und
knoblauch zwiebeln brennen und dann auch
die gewürze und kann den verein machen
und ich vermisse es jetzt schon mal gut
am besten verknetet die zutaten ganz
kurz mit den händen dann vermischen sie
sich nämlich besser passen wir auch
leere
wieso eine ärztin
der teig dürfte jetzt ruhen und jetzt
kann ich ihnen portionieren ich werde
jetzt nämlich ausrollen
das können jetzt entweder mit einem
ausrollt starb machen oder mit seinem
türkischen ob beraten sind ganz langer
dünner aus rolf starb oder er macht mit
der nudelmaschine soweit ich das machen
jetzt teile ich den ersten mal in acht
portionen 11 kommen nur vier portionen
und könnte es dann direkt ausrollen
jetzt haben wir hier eine kugel und
brauchen wir nicht da kommt noch du das
zum ausrollen benötigten teig jetzt ein
bisschen und dann rolle ich so ganz
lange platten aus
die teigplatten halbiere ich jetzt will
nämlich sehr lang und dann wird jede
zeigt also nochmal gedrittelt und zwar
längst
und da jetzt zeit zu sparen könnt ihr
euch jetzt alle schon mal vorbereiten
ich mach das nochmal hier immer auf
meiner holz arbeitsplatte da kann ich
alles schön nebeneinander legen und aber
da kann ich nicht viel und skizziert
jetzt kommen immer so kleine
fleischstückchen hier mit drauf
jetzt werden die teigstücke immer hier
zusammen gedrückt so dass man in der
mitte dann noch titel hackfleisch stück
sieht
und jetzt werden die nudel teile einfach
noch in sich zusammen gerollt und
dadurch entsteht eben richtig schöne
optik und so lege ich jetzt in der große
auflaufform rein
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch ein
backblech benutzen da müsste nur darauf
achten dass ein tiefes blech ist denn da
kommt gleich eine soße mit rein
die nudeln schmecken habe ich jetzt hier
einmal in einem großen blick und einmal
in einer kleinen auflockern und die
werden jetzt zuerst einmal vor gebacken
im ofen bei 200 10 grad für ungefähr 15
minuten
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich um die
tomatensoße herzustellen
für die tomatensoße frau ich 400 gramm
tomaten dem stromkabel bereits entfernt
eine rote paprika eine zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe drei esslöffel tomatenmark
etwas zucker eine prise pfeffer und ich
habe ich noch ein liter gemüsebrühe und
die muss jetzt richtig gut gehalten sein
denn der nudelteig ist er nicht gesalzen
und entzieht er sich das salz einfach
aus der gemüse früher raus die soße geht
jetzt wirklich ganz schnell einfach nur
einen mixer dafür
und da kommen die ganzen zutaten rein
noch drei ist auf tomatenmark und
pfeffer
dass wir das alles gut durchgesetzt
und die soße kommt jetzt direkt auf die
nudeln schmecken die jetzt schon seit 15
minuten im ofen sind
jetzt guck ich nur dass die schönen
damit bedeckt sind dann werden sie
nämlich jeder weiß
und dann müssen sie für etwa 25 minuten
noch mal weich gegart werden
die nudeln schmecken sind jetzt gebacken
und wir sehen auch wirklich super hübsch
aus hat auch so ein bisschen was von
lasagne und jetzt mache ich dann noch
eine joghurt soße mit dazu für die
joghurt soße brauche ich 600 gramm
joghurt der 10 anteil eine knoblauchzehe
einen halben teelöffel salz halben
teelöffel getrocknete minseln pfeffer
und dann brauche ich noch eine butter
soße und dafür habe ich jetzt hier 40
gramm butter und paprikapulver und
paprikapulver edelsüß dann die sanierer
später noch mit ist kann ich zuerst
einmal die butter auf einen herd geben
mit dem topf und sie ganz heiß werden
lassen und in der zwischenzeit werde ich
schon mal gut mit den restlichen zutaten
verrühren
die knoblauchzehe wird jetzt dazu
gegeben
jetzt kann ich alles mit einem
schneebesen glattrühren
sobald ich ganz geschmolzen ist kommt
jetzt das mögliche getan würde so
richtig lecker
machen sie auch mit niemand drüber man
sie auch manchmal die sich sowas endet
sobald es jetzt hier so ein bisschen auf
schäumt nachricht ist auch richtig
bericht sehr toll könnte den herd
ausschalten
jetzt sind wir fertig die jugend so
solltet ihr auf jeden fall nochmal
abschmecken wenn die fehlt ein bisschen
salz und knoblauch
natürlich freuen sich alle meine
arbeitskollegen natürlich und zwar ganze
woche jetzt kannst du mir einen schon
deinen teller geben denn schon fertig
also ist es ist auch ein einfaches
rezept finde ich und ihr könnt es zum
beispiel gut vorbereiten ihr könnt diese
schmecken ja schon formen in den blech
setzen und im kühlschrank lagern und
dann kurz bevor eure gäste zum beispiel
kommen einfach noch in den backofen
schieben kann man die auch ein kann die
super einfrieren der moral ist alles auf
jersey nets mit stella und rang sieben
für eine klausur um die frage zu
beantworten ja man kann die rohen teig
stücke auch einfrieren
dafür legte sie einfach auf dem
backpapier und zum beispiel auf einen
torten retter können sie einfrieren und
sobald die teile gebrochen sind könnte
sich schön einpacken und aufbewahren
soll jetzt sage ich aber nicht nochmal
so kann ich serviere jetzt direkt jedem
umfragen sind
was kann man die auch einfrieren bevor
gespuckt franco gewicht aber patrick
patrick star
so hat hier eine teig schnecke natürlich
gibt's pro portion mehrere also zwei bis
drei würde ich schon sagen dann kommt da
die joghurt soße drüber wenn ihr
übrigens mehr tomatensoße möchtet müsst
ihr einfach nur mal ein bisschen nach
gießen also noch ein bisschen mehr
machen
ich finde allerdings so schon gut weil
ich finde bei mir ist der joghurt die
sofort müssen doch typisch ja so ähnlich
als ich habe auch so ein rezept schon
mal gemacht das ist ein bisschen anders
denn ich habe hier keine reine
tomatensoße eine tomaten paprika so
jetzt hab ich probiere ich weiß
eigentlich schon das ist genial
ich finde es genial aus als es sieht
wirklich nicht so genial sagen und die
zuschauer zählen schon bei mir wird
nicht mal gezielt jetzt schon mal 5 bei
mir ist einfach und lecker die kamera
er hat seine sache jetzt auszupacken
bitte sie seien gerade jetzt rein guckt
man es für sich
aber hier das hackfleisch drin die
positiv so leicht kalt dann diese
paprika creme also schon also ich finde
es genial und ich auch schon geahnt
angesteckt ich mag das halt wenn die
teig stecken ganz heiß sind und dann
eben diese kalte joghurt soße dazu kommt
das finde ich richtig super unglaublich
falls sie jetzt auch durch moritz
schmatzen appetit auf dieses rezept
bekommen habt dann geht auch sallys
blog.de kann ja aufhören zu schneiden
reicht es ist nicht schön vielleicht
einfach aufhören zu essen macht doch
einfach nicht wer es noch gleich
zusammen über auffällig - block der
vorstand nur kopien fernsehsendungen da
essen sie auch nicht alles auf die
probieren nur einen löffel und dann
geht's weiter
ich bin kein star co ich bin bereit ich
wissen also das rezept steht das
lieblings blog de heraus ist ich wünsche
euch viel spaß beim nachkochen und beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal wieder
bis dahin tschüss was er ein habe ich
noch ist schlicht genial absolut genial
kommt es war genial